greetings apiece welcome to the D show
now before a tragic incident happens
like what we saw just recently with
little Kris you know little Kris and not
too long ago so some own battle
X Factor star these people now young
adults going through depression did you
know that depression is something that
is at all-time high you have close to
20% of high schools students are
considerably seriously considering
suicide and that suicide is the second
leading cause of death between the ages
of 10 and 24 now we thought that this
was just among adults this deep
depression depression and despair
but now it's leading over to the youth
so how can we prevent someone from
jumping off a bridge from Zayn Malik
leaving the band and then you got your
daughter's starting to joining the
hashtag cut for Zayn we want to nip it
in the bud early that's why experts tell
us that from the ages now when the kids
are born 4 5 6 start really doing
getting these parenting skills getting
the tips that are needed so we can go
ahead and be responsible parents so then
we can have it responsible adults
growing up who can be an asset to
society instead of a detriment to
themselves and society with my next
guests here in the Dean show
don't go anywhere we're going to be
covering this very important topic right
back
this is the this is the beam you know
this is the thesis the teacher is the
mean you know this is the monocle Salaam
- lightweight catchy have you heard a
little Wayne yes Lil Wayne Lil Wayne I
meant low Kris there's there's little
Wayne he's still alive rapper's is he's
still rapping he didn't quit the integer
lifestyle - you know okay - go what
about what about the look you heard a
little Chris just discourse this event
that happened now and then I mentioned
another famous celebrity a lot of famous
celebrities now I mentioned this because
now some people like Eddie whadya
fascination with some of these
celebrities not that is that we're
creatures of limitation and our youth
lot of times and even adults we mimic a
lot of the celebrity celebrities that
are out there and we see that you know
the happiness is not there so to prevent
a lot of these things from happening how
can we gain benefit so what are some of
the things now that you and your
experience that you've seen I'm Nate
I've labeled the suicide
you know the depression on the rise
really and we're not immune to it also
as Muslims this has really hit home
you've seen some of these things happen
jail kids under nap in jail what else
indeed well you know the interesting
thing obviously when you look at Islam
we have this inner source of peace if
you will for those who study Islam who
are open to it and keeping the hearts
open and as a parent we fear a lot of
the same ills that are massive and
rampant through our society affect our
children like I've seen Muslim children
we're not immune from any of those
things whether it be going to jail even
as teenagers going to jail as Muslims
not going to jail then becoming Muslim
but actually being raising the Muslim
household becoming incarcerated for some
heinous crimes the same thing when it
comes to drugs alcohol denouncing Islam
totally just saying you know what I
don't believe in it you know raising the
most
household and the interesting thing is
that many times as parents we tend to
feel we're doing our best
or our parenting is good or we're immune
from a lot of challenges of society
because we're Muslims and we have the
truth of Islam when that's actually not
the case now this has become something
that is soaring out of seems out of
control like same in you know here at
home where you think now okay now I'm
Muslim I'm getting you know myself
together with with Islam but then I
don't I'm not developing the proper
skills because you might come from a
culture now that you think how I raised
my children 30 40 you know how I was
very steady 40 years ago now in this
culture I'm going to go ahead and
implement these things here and it seems
to backfire absolutely if you look at
the world 3040 years ago just in the
advancement of technology and how so
much fitness now at our at our
fingertips literally not even a click
with just a touch where the Internet is
not with us at any moment or think about
it how many children know they know the
internet better than their parents even
know it you know what I'm saying so what
may have worked for me when I was
younger but not work for necessarily
work for the children today and then
that would also assume that I was raised
with great parents and great parenting
skills you know so if you are for
example obviously we live in the West
many people are immigrants to the West
and they're first generation so their
children are first generation born here
but they don't know the landscape they
might know back home if they're desi in
Pakistan or India or Jordan or
throughout the Arab world or the Middle
East or North Africa but this is new to
them this is the new landscape or on the
flip side is you have a person who
accepted Islam or converted like myself
born and raised everything except Islam
but I know the history of this country
and the landscape of this country and
how to maneuver better than someone
who's brand new if that makes sense
yeah you know and with our children the
challenge comes in when when we decide
to proactively parent when we actually
look at our parenting see what our
skills are what our goals are for our
children and do something about it
because is one thing just get advice
people say you know you should be
patient be loving provide them a great
Islamic education send them to an
Islamic school
we'll be fine just make dua for them
okay advice is okay however I need
something that's practical how do I deal
with a situation when there are boys and
girls for example in the coming of age
and hormones are not wanting you know
what I do about snapchat app that
children are likely familiar with me ask
your child to have a snapchat account in
and why you know you check their phones
they may have it or they may just hide
it from you
you know snapchat is kind of the new
sexting app if you will you know because
the children believe or people believe
that you can utilize the app then your
information disappears no matter what
you send okay so whether it be that or
Instagram which I know Dean shall just
start a new Instagram account enjoying
the social media revolution we're really
getting Dean information out there but
how many are using it for negative
purposes you know my question is
apparent is it how many I have have
right now at the time of account my
children and their ages have four
beautiful daughters four beautiful sons
another son on the way and then two
stepchildren saw a big family and
they're all they range from different
ages from nineteen years old all the way
down to two so if a college student all
the way down to a two year old so I'm in
ages you know they're different needs
and different ages from teenagers all
the way on down but the question is when
do children start forming their
personality and start paying attention
to different things going on society how
can we pay attention to that as parents
we know it's incumbent in the Dean to
constantly to be seeking knowledge so
you have the doctor the realtor you know
the typical professional he seeks a
continuing education to excel in this
field is this where we need to now do
some sort of continuing education to
enhance our parenting skills I believe
that's imperative but a lot to Allah
ordered us in Quran Allah taught us in
surah tehreem the six ayah in
translation or Allah Allah says o you
believe save yourselves and your
families from the fire whose fuel is men
in stone then it goes on but to save
yourself is the command from Allah to
Allah so we have to do what we can we
must remember the profits of some time
let us know that three things will
follow us after our death you know and
skip to the third is the righteous child
that prays for you the key word is a
righteous child they're not right you're
not going to benefit you you know so
we have this command from Allah to Allah
in the promise of the problem of course
is impaired is imperative on us because
no matter how much risk or how much
money we make when it comes to being a
realtor or physician and all the rest is
and we have all the toys the toys aren't
what's going to eventually save you
that's not what a lots of other values
and to think about it just as you open
the show you mentioned these suicide
people who are millionaires wanted me to
have all the toys all the things around
them but they have this emptiness inside
and help you like we know that Islam
feels that so we'll go into in Charlotte
Allah some some different techniques to
look for and to look at but ultimately
we have to decide to be proactive
parents to make sure our skills are just
as keen as outside skills for a job or a
career or for our physical health
because again this is a path to Jenna
and all that's how to get is giving
these children as in a manner so we must
feel fulfilled that trust with that
trust we're going to write back so we
can empower the youth at a young age so
they don't end up thinking about suicide
let alone committing it or ending up in
jail or any other thing that will end up
not benefiting them us or society we'll
be right back with more here on the Deen
show please subscribe to the DCO follow
us on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Deen show you have a lot of
parents who'll come to the mom to the
shake to someone who's qualified to give
advice and now once the ship is sail
they'll come and they'll say can you fix
my child can you say something they
think that okay I'm going to say some
magic words some do I and all of a
sudden he's going to be a student and
you have he witnessed this but of course
in lead too many times um when it comes
to as a parent has lost influence and
what I suggest what we teach the
obviously the outstanding most
appearance is that we have to utilize
our influence and our roles effectively
for example in our children are born
their newborns they look up to the
parents we're all they had were their
best friends we're everything for them
right they look up to us what we do they
imitate or offer salat they're trying to
offer select with us and all of these
different things we get happy about it
we have huge influencing if you look at
it like a circle when our children are
young
this big circle of influence the parents
are the most influential and we consider
that one of the three C's or what call
the celebrity they they look up to us as
parents as celebrities so first we have
to be that role model okay
as children get older that sphere of
influence increases now they meet
different uncles aunts grandparents
friends different Society once they get
it to television Internet then it's the
media so this spirit of influence grows
however if the parent hasn't
went deep or dug into their child touch
their hearts then the parents influence
tend to shrink so that's when I go to a
share or someone else and say come talk
to this child now that happened to me
when I was younger so before I accepted
Islam people say hey you no need to talk
this boy he's on the wrong path and I
was raising Christian school
kindergarten in tenth grade I saw more
drugs going on there more sexual and
illicit relationships going on inside
this Christian school where parents were
thinking that you were given a high
quality of education and the children
would be righteous when it was the exact
opposite unfortunately the same type of
thinking is going on with Muslim parents
they fake hey if I say no to an Islamic
school hey they'll come out okay
like as though we putting them in an
assembly line on one end and then it pop
out these ideal Muslim citizens which
again isn't the case so when it comes to
influence as parents we have to know how
to touch their hearts we have to go deep
we have to love them but at the same
time we have to make sure we are being
these practicing Muslims that we want
our children to be so they're not
offering salat it's kind of hard to take
a child to office a lot yeah you know
being that celebrity so we have to lead
by example first then we could have to
find out when to go strong with them as
in developing their insights what are
they liking what are their likes you
know it's not haram for them to get
involved with sports to do something
physical but at the same time we have to
be feeding their mind on am a Muslim we
have to build up their Islamic identity
see the only reason I wear a cool fee
because I was learning Islam earlier
this the COO fees even from Islam
however its associated with being Muslim
the only reason I wear is really in
solidarity with our sisters who have to
wear the kymaro when they go out and
have to be covered properly so that they
know there's a Muslim around if they
need some type of help or when other
people are asking to have my beard
almost an eight are you Muslim yeah you
know that's one of the ways they
recognize me
not again that even has anything to do
with Islam because it's worn prior to
but that Islamic identity and most of my
identity I want to be an example for my
children on who we are because obviously
when they look up to celebrities whether
it be the Zayn Malik cut for Zayn or
what have you they're looking up to
someone to emulate but they don't know
their feelings or their thought to their
concepts all they see is this public
persona that get puts out just like DC
Comics coming up with their gay
superhero like why would
sexuality have anything to do with these
superheroes and these stories they're
putting their children other than to
program a property and propagate
propaganda so we as parents have to be
aware of this it's not something that's
just oh there's just little kids right
now the more we think they're little
kids right now and they're not
processing and their brain neurons
aren't firing off the more we're doing a
disservice and on the negative side
we're now as our children grow older and
they don't want off so they don't want
to do these Islamic things I think
that's uncool we begin to look at our
pairing and say you know I should have
done better could have done better but
and insert any excuse that you wish one
part of continuing education for me and
sometimes connecting and talking to some
of the youth to see some of the
challenges and you just get blown away
sometimes when they tell you some of the
stories and they'll open up they feel
comfortable they'll tell you really you
know because you kind of get isolated
doing your own thing and you get
disconnected but then you get
reconnected with the youth so is that
one of the things really having an open
communication with your children that
they can come to you they trust you not
that every time they want to come to you
and just say this is Haram this is hippy
not with explaining it and you know
really harsh with them and not having
this this openness that you can
communicate if I play loud the great
part is mothers are more emotionally
balanced to be able to deal with the
children and face the fact when they're
younger mothers are the ones who are
around the children more more often than
not okay so being able to come to them
and being more approachable as a mother
it's huge of course as a father it is as
well but usually children go to the
mother you know in general generally
speaking now you of course you have to
be approachable if you're not approached
where they going to go find find it
somewhere else find somebody who's
lending an ear we don't know what their
and tensions are it could be some boy
you have a daughter but it's some boy
that's willing to lend an ear until how
beautiful she is and how this is okay
and so on and so forth
so the main thing is communication
that's that second see or that confidant
we have to teach your children how to be
able to read between the lines because
you have to teach them if you see a
commercial coming on us all commercial
during the Super Bowl a few years ago
and or playoffs or something and it was
a Pepsi commercial a soda commercial but
during the soda commercial they had they
show tanks and they showed the soldiers
just throwing different cases and they
show people at home and are all smiling
and wearing a red white and blue and all
of this conditioning in a matter of a
30-second commercial and asked my
children you know what was that about
and I heard their opinions I said you
know really it's about programming and
what's going on in the Middle East in
the Muslim world and how we need to
support our troops and so on and so
forth because that in my opinion was the
message they were sending with this
little tidbit as I was happy it's fine
support your team enjoy Pepsi and lick
what we're doing the Middle East for our
soldiers so to get you riled up in these
emotions we have to be smart enough as
parents to help our children read
between the lines so that they'll come
to us when they have questions and
they'll trust our insight because at
first they may not believe you when you
tell them what's going on in a real
world because we're in this Muslim
bubble if you will but as they meet more
people and as their circle of influence
grows and they may go to school or
college they come across people they
come across things that will shock them
and we can't shelter our children from
that we just prepared them Islamic Lee
because the world is the world there's
beauty in it is ugliness in it we have
to do what we can to make sure that
foundation is strong and they're strong
with their Muslim personality know that
the source of true peace and success is
Islam and there is there are methods and
ways with which to do that in Charlotte
we can give some tangible steps some
tangible things that people can leave
off of the program and then also you
have some of your your materials but
before we when we come back from break
you give us some more tangible things
lists we can be like they can leave with
after the show good ok we'll be right
back for more here on the Dean show or
anywhere please subscribe to the D show
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below
welcome back to the Dean show so much to
cover we're just given some tidbits so
we can nip it as I said in the bud so we
can help prevent the children from
falling into becoming despondent into
despair suicide drugs promiscuity
immorality insanity parenting the right
way from an early age and you have so
much I mean there's just so much going
on out there and the parent says look
guys I you know work two jobs
my wife's working we come home now we're
fried and they just put the TV on and
the kids sitting next to the TV and just
till he falls asleep maybe get some
homework done I can't what
I gotta get that I gotta get paid there
was little to K goes to values values
and priorities what do you say in these
days it's not even us reading TV you
just throw Netflix on stream something
on TV or the Internet
you know what I want to talk about
though cuz I asked me was thinking I'm
going to Dean show would you like me to
discuss and one was really disciplined
they talk about stubbornness and a lot
of things one is discipline and it's
very important that we understand this
point discipline is really twofold
because Islam is disciplined when we
think of Islam we pray five times a day
we know when we have to pray we know
what we have to say in each archive
right we know how to fast how what so
who is what time would begin the fast
with time we rush for your thought we
know all of these things you know hide
you did and Hajj is not easy but Aslam
is disciplined right there are things
that we can do things that were not
doing and so on so we have this system
in place and similarly with discipline
we have known understands apparent this
when it does not equate just equaling
punishment many times thing that child
needs to be disciplined but when you
think of an athlete who was strong who
was very well he's very disciplined okay
pricey schools more discipline as
opposed to public sometimes I mean I
went to private school and actually it
really is when it comes to educational
styles and so on but the main thing is
as a parent we have to be first of all
disciplined discipline in our parenting
can't be lazy have to be proactive but
here's what I mean about discipline 90%
of discipline with our children is
training discipline 10% will be
corrective discipline which is sometimes
people call punishment for example so
the training discipline is like with a
share that third seat we're cheerleading
them we're showing them how to office a
lot we're having different discussions
they were picking their brains they're
asking questions because we ask
questions you have to listen as opposed
to don't do this can't do that but now
your child knows what you want to hear
not want to hear and can avoid you and
give you what you want in this space
while in public they have a whole
different phase okay
so training discipline but when we get
to corrective discipline here's a
challenge there are different ways to do
it now sometimes you know I'm sure
you've seen at the Masjid children just
run a while running around wild act like
they have no home training parents not
doing anything about it and so on max
could be up there could be a time in a
place for playing and rustling and so on
it's like the promise of selamat get
paying you used to do you know the
master they should be raised around a
master however there are there's a code
of conduct and etiquette that must go
along with it so when people ask me
about discipline say you know one of the
first things I do for example my
children that is effective is a stair it
could be someone's not acting right and
I get their attention I just do a stair
let me know
get in line settle down relax behave
properly appropriately next level maybe
raising your voice you know cuz if I'm
talking with you and me Eddie Eddie
now of course don't have any sons or
Eddie but just raising a voice to get
their attention now if you're always
yelling and screaming do the opposite
because when you get quiet if you're a
screamer and you get quiet as a mother
and I'm kind of saying there's a lot of
times but I do yell or they might go off
is to be quiet change your physiology do
something different change your pattern
which is not familiar with your pattern
Oh mom's just yelling again but now I
was getting quiet now I must be serious
so you might raise your voice you could
elevate all the way and one things I
really like is conditioning so whether
doing burpees or push-ups and you know
being in mixed martial arts that many
times when you're straining your body
your body's concentrating is lactic acid
is building up then you their brain has
more time to concentrate now so now you
can speak with a child that might be in
a horse position in kung-fu horse
position or push-up position or after
getting down some burpees in there
they're really breathing your
conditioning and strengthening in their
body while you're trying to get through
to their mind all the way to the point
of people say spanking now here's a
challenge so no you should have spanked
it Islam should have
physical physical time now there's a
such thing as abuse I was abused as a
child I was physically abused a child
now when I was a child you know when I
get older I'll never with my children
and all this kind of stuff
yeah that's out the window there's a
time and a place for when something is
an intentional totally respectful way
out of order and so on and that's good
to be something to get them back in line
there's a time to place for that and the
reason I said this time place for that
because a process of solemn said
teachers young to prayer seven if not
did to hit them at ten you know so
sometimes a translator has hit them or
spanked them or some say beat them I
like the word beat because specifically
English beat has a whole different
definition okay then maybe someone who's
a foreigner but there are these
different stages and the process um
wouldn't allow something to say
something that even though he may not
have practiced it that wouldn't be
allowed okay
very very important but that's extreme
cases because you can quickly and easily
abuse and go about above and beyond the
authority you have as a parent and also
said now you have to answer to Allah
Allah for that you know the answer I
lost trust why that's abuse how did you
abuse that when I sent the perfect
example problem to deal with it now the
difference is when we were raised thirty
years ago twenty years ago this
technology wasn't saying that it's today
100 years ago even I mean from not
flying in planes or having new planes
and four color TVs with technology has
allowed this world people say many times
the world as a village now you can get
stuff at your fingertips which is so
true so we have to ingrain our Islamic
personality in our children so that we
can have this bond of trust with them
one of the ways of course is to
understand discipline the others to
start young we ask questions we look at
people like I live and I will talk
called overly Aloha and who accepted
Islam before he was ten years old and
how these people were treated as men as
early teens if I'm something regularly
accepted a person that a man at fifteen
years old to go on fighting different
battles we think of fifteen year olds
today and they're like big kids so
there's not really a rites of passage
program so what we like what we've done
without setting most appearance of
course we've wrote it in the book
Muslims parenting on purpose and in
different products to really just share
specific strategy when it comes to
building men who are masculine who are
at the same time working towards being
providers and they're looking at
examples of heroes you you have these
companions ISA Harbor already by one
wide rain you have so many different
examples of people who will be
considered legendary if they just take
one of these companions and put it in a
movie it to be like a legend where they
have to really go so far makeup and
better so many stories in general
Hollywood I'm talking about to have this
one big heroic fictional story like the
William Wallace Braveheart move people
loved it but it's mostly fiction where
you can look at what we did in Islamic
certainly mohammed el fat and so on to
really help build this Islamic character
and our children to strive for it but we
have to be proud of the first as parents
we can't hide our Islamic hide our Deen
because ultimately we are going to
return to Allah Tala
so seeking dunya is permissible but
don't trade that for your aqua doors
Allah Ta'ala tells of rubber nights and
if it dunya husana what fill our karate
has no I mean all that but not you know
very very crucial yeah so we talked
about these different aspects and other
thing we got to go but I just watched a
very very good documentary I really
recommend because another thing that
also doesn't help is the kind of diet
that the kids are at obesity is on the
rise fed up have you seen his doctor in
excess watch two days ago yeah and we
feeding our children poison basically
and this is affecting them you know not
only physically mentally and this is
another thing that we need to get up on
also isn't it absolutely I mean there's
some several documentaries I mean living
on a dollar a day to help us be grateful
to see how people's are called living on
a dollar a day okay
you know most of the world actually I
think it's about sixty percent of world
earns less than two dollars a day
mm-hm so to teach gratefulness to racial
masters yeah you know very very
important of course fed up of course
were parenting and what we're doing to
our children unknowingly and unwittingly
with these processed foods you have the
Gerson miracle when it comes to eating
naturally and actually being healthy you
have it there's so many that our
beneficial remember props are some said
that there are two things that we waste
more anything else health and spare time
and all of these are components now to
live a good wholesome successful life
and what you are also doing how can
people now we get a little taste to nip
it in the bud but how can people get a
hold of you
and also get some of this honey left
thank ya thank you always what I want to
do actually for Dean so show viewers
first off is is my book almost Muslims
parenting on purpose and what I want to
do is give all of your viewers opps when
you get for free now normally retails in
1795 in Barnes Noble and numerous
bookstores and what I'll do is if you go
to outstanding most appearances on TV
slash Dean show I will give it to you
for free you just have to pay shipping
so anywhere in the world you just have
to go ahead and pay shipping and I'll
send you the book where we go through
the three C's and a lot of parenting
tips and at the same time we have an
audio program as well for those who may
drive a lot or want to just go ahead and
put it on their smartphone or tablet
it's a six-cd course that we get deep
into as well and of course any Dean show
individually will put whatever discounts
we have a six-week course where we
created a television show went through
an entire season for a television show
on parenting specifically and so we
addressed a number of different things
that we go deep whether it be dealing
with music and entertainment when
they're dealing with discipline and
sports and history and really building
culture and our children and that's
called a six week outstanding parenting
home study course we have known DVD as
well as online but the best ways to get
in contact with us is outstanding most
of parents dot TV or of course watch the
Dean show and get their special link so
I can send you something for free and
Charlotte oh thank you very much
design low fuss or yeah cool thank you
jaeseok Lahaina something from our TV
salawatullahi way to get to thank you
and thank you for tuning in to the Dean
show these are great reminders for
everybody including myself you know
having children and then we all just get
caught up into the different activities
that we're doing work in business and
and many of the priorities that we have
in our lives but as the hadith that is
you know very important our guests have
mentioned that the things that we leave
behind because we're going to leave this
dunya behind and one of them skipping to
the third is a righteous child so to go
ahead and prevent as I open up the show
with the extreme examples of the suicide
rates among children the depression and
some of these celebrities that people
are imitating them going to the top then
plummet
now way to the bottom and then our
guests that they are giving some great
examples now of children just going
towards drugs and alcohol and ending up
in jail
so now if we invest in this priceless
investment now we get reminded from the
program we can go back have a great
communication not abusing our children
no but communicating being the celebrity
us being the celebrity role models in
their lives and doing things the proper
way so they can be an asset to society
they can grow to be positive good human
beings and make a difference in the
world
subscribe if you haven't already to the
Deen show now you can join us also onto
Instagram share our shows follow us on
Facebook Twitter we'll see you next time
God will until then peace be with you
please subscribe to the D show follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below